right so it's really great that have
Manfred here probably with dropout
preservation so that special week
yeah special week right okay so I talked
about dropout perturbations and you know
this is something we we discovered this
independently and laid it later on we
noticed we were doing dropout so dropout
is usually known you a networker context
you know some kind of a layered nor a
net and you know you you feed your
inputs computation goes forwards and
then the the they trained with
stochastic gradient descent and your
your gradients are propagated backwards
with back pop now the dropout training
is you randomly set throw out half of it
to throw out notes with probability one
half you have a remaining network and
you just do your training based on that
net that network there's many variations
of it and we are doing variations of it
with just one single neuron and in
practice this works better in some
contexts but of course everything is
changing all the times in the world of
heuristics some people tell me that
tripod is not so important anymore
but we found something that works for a
single neuron is drop out like at least
and it has these interesting properties
drop out noise okay and it was why does
it work
and so forth but we only do it for a
single neuron and linear loss so now I
explained to you the expert advice
setting which is the basic setting one
of the basic settings in the cult
community for which we have very tight
bounds and then we apply to drop out no
and we had some advantages and that kind
of noise is independently interesting a
lot of people here in the room have
worked on various noises so expert
setting is something like you have a
bunch of experts they predict something
it's rain it's not gonna rain then you
have a master algorithm that combines
the prediction predict zero because
there was more zeroes maybe then you get
a true label and you get a loss there
was a disagreement next day the experts
predict again the master prediction
might be a one now get the label and you
have a loss you have no loss because
they agreed in general you have some
predictions from the experts prediction
of the master true label absolute loss
it's a very simple thing you can predict
the number in 0 & 1 yeah that's what
it's usually yes but I'm gonna abstract
this away in a moment so here yes see so
these are in between 0 & 1 and the y hat
is between 0 & 1 the true label might be
binary yeah there's many versions of
this good so the idea is that the master
algorithm takes a weighted combinations
of the predictions of the experts very
simple model so the mass talcum predicts
with W of X and WI is to believe an
expert I in some sense and now notice
that in this particular case when the
label is 0 or 1 the loss actually
linearizes in other words because this
is binary it linearizes okay so now we
come to a very simple linear model so
this is the the first one with absolute
loss where you get an X vector you're
predictable the weighted combination you
get the true label the expert get this
component wise loss and then this is the
loss of the master which is a weighted
combination this can be abstracted away
to what we call in in machine learning
the hedge setting where instead of
feeding inputs you can view it as the
following you view
experts getting lost vectors at the end
of each trial that a numbers between
zero and one and then the model is very
simple and this is going to be my mase
basic model so this one you have to
understand you have a weight vector
which is your parameter you get a loss
vector at the end of the trial and then
the expert incurs this individual loss
this is a number between 0 & 1 and then
the master algorithm is charged by the
weighted loss by WL so what you what
your objective is you get these you have
these arms and they feed you losses you
are supposed to put all your weight on
the good guys that have no losses have
very little losses right and you want to
do this in online fashion here the game
yeah and I'm what I made make this has
this has this in some sense as a special
case therefore this justifies this
abstraction that's the idea okay so when
you predict with a weight vector and so
the weight vector is a is a probability
vector instead of predicting with a
probability vector you might as well
pick an X but at random and pick with
that one
that's interchangeable yes is it a
proper schooling work this is not a
proper schooling we we use we don't use
this by itself we just judged by that we
judged by this linear losses but we
predict with proper scrolling ones
because we add regularization z' let me
it's a very good question we'll get to
that okay
then the proper Ness is sort of
introduced by the noise okay good so now
as I said the game is you have a
probability vector you might predict an
expert you might choose an expert at
random from that probability vector you
get your loss vector each x but as a
loss between 0 & 1 then the mass that is
true is charged by WL
which is the expected loss if you picked
it at random then your loss is the
expert you picked x LT so it would be LT
I T but in expectation this is the same
so I'm going to switch back and forth
between these things so this is a basic
trick there's nothing deep about it okay
good
and then you update your weight vector
okay this is the game okay good
the weights over here implicit okay good
what is our criterion for success it's a
regret so I'm really have a very basic
problem we do this iterative game this
is the loss of the expected loss of the
Mast algorithm and what do I compare
against the best loss in hindsight so
this is my notation I looked at the lost
vector this is I sum up all the losses
in component I this is the total loss of
expert I I'm going for the best this is
the loss of expert of the master
algorithm ad loss T at time T and I sum
over all trials I know get that gap
that's called the regret with me this is
a totally ridiculous loss in some sense
because it's all linear right so it says
no properness of anything but we will
predict with proper things somehow by
adding noise so it's a very slippery
thing because it's linear right simply
vs. should be very suspicious but we can
prove bounds in the community we have
there's a huge family of algorithms and
we forget that a dropout works and it
has some additional magic it's very cute
so this dropout noise is very cute
so here the algorithms okay again now I
don't put predictions down for the
experts I put losses down right so this
is my day one here were the losses they
two were the losses day t minus one
where the losses so what I do is I have
sort of a sufficient statistic I add up
all the losses so far so this is my
losses thing that's one way that's one
thing and now I can do follow the leader
follow the leader says
pick predict with the expert I have the
smallest loss yet so I would predict
with these two 5050
you see let's follow the leader right if
you deterministic for the leader would
actually predict with a particular guy
off the best that's even that's worse
but randomized is better but you predict
with the best they said let's follow the
leader I'm trying to and they start talk
about things you could teach in the
machine learning class right basic basic
ideas okay good so another one son Joe
is here I think is you have additive
noise so you take this total losses you
add additive noise don't buy some kind
of a stretch factor okay let's follow
the perturbed leader you understand
follow the perturb leader okay and and a
third one is soft min soft min would be
you take these total losses you put them
in an exponent with a negative side
scale factor and normalize that means it
puts weights on the guise of small loss
but in a continuous fashion soft min
yeah so if you let learning red go to
infinity this would be equal to that and
it turns out you will see that this
algorithm you can simulate with this
algorithm as you will see in a moment or
vice versa
what's dropout
it's not even politics okay good so now
what's true what's drop out drop out is
you don't add noise what you do is you
cross out the ones with uniform
probability the zero sit across that
doesn't make a difference
so everybody's everything is dropped
with probability 1/2
you see you ant your tally and then you
go with the leader so in this case you
would go with this guy way in this
particular case because there was only
one zero no yes yes it's always it in
there's lots of randomness involved
because you cross randomly and then you
pick amongst the leaders uniformly ok
good so pictorially what happens is I'm
not in a neural network case I'm in a
very naive small case single neuron one
neuron and now I dropped with you
probability 1/2
you see and so it's sort of and then I
take them take the the leader fall on
the leader I go with the best very
simple noise so some people I showed
this to Hinton in this particular
context and he says ok its
multiplicative noise because you instead
of adding to the losses something right
people have actually added there's a
Bernoulli random variable you couldn't
take your total losses and add Pauline
William Bernoulli random variables for
each trial has certain problems here
what you do is you do multiplicative
noise and it turns out that
multiplicative noise will you wipe out
has has advantages and that's what this
talk is about okay so everybody
understand this yes go ahead
repeat the cross sounds the drop of
every duration yes yes independently
independently and this is really when we
take something you know see you get each
time a new row you have the past or each
time you get a new row you drop out and
you do your predictions and at the end
of the trial you you drop and complete
you recompute your tallies and each time
you follow the leader of your yes really
stupid why would you drop this valuable
data right why would you of course you
want to have robustness and this is the
whole thing and in this particular
context it does the optimal thing if you
drop these are you would not want to
drop I mean additive noise makes a
little bit of sense but you know you
just add noise variable so can you blur
but you keep all the information maybe
I'm right here you drop all your value
of the data why would you do that yeah
now there's an alternate version I
Belize get to follow the skipping leader
which is where we are that we wanted to
prove works where you would take the
whole row and drop it with probability
1/2 I get back to that one that would
have many advantages and we were after
that never proved anything about it and
finally somebody showed us a counter
example it doesn't work in our worst
case criteria so we needed the
independence on the components okay so
it's a study of what kind of noise is
good okay and I show you the proof
techniques and they were kind of
interesting so how good well we know
that in this case the best algorithm the
best regret you can achieve is this
upper and lower bounds it's log of the
number of experts and then a square root
term whether the and this is the loss of
the best so the loss of the best appears
in the bound the loss of the best expert
you understand what I mean so this is
the regret you can have algorithms
and drop out is going to be one of them
that achieves this optimum require the
algorithm just runs along and you can
always guarantee this bound yeah okay
good now let me talk about the
algorithms a little bit very interesting
so follow-the-leader is bad for many
reasons
because you somehow the adversary knows
too much what you're doing and you can
fool you and I will give you hints of
that in a moment to get your flavor
white works now follow the pattern play
that you randomness the adversary
doesn't know what you're doing because
it doesn't know your randomness right
that's what we assume but and this works
well it gets the optimum bound but you
need to tune the learning rate as a
function of L star if you have a lot of
learn if you have a lot of noise if you
ever if the loss of the best is very
high then you don't want to do a lot of
updates if your loss of the of the best
is very low you want to have a large ADA
and you need to know what regime you are
in to get the good bounds
now now dropout requires no tuning
that's its first feet it's totally
trivial it's let it's not additive noise
its multiplicative noise and it achieves
this bound ok constants always ignored
so it gets the optimum regret and which
is very cute and that's why I'm in this
workshop and it also is good in in the
benevolent data case when your data is
iid ok when your data is iid and there's
sort of a gap between the first and the
second then it even figures out figure
it's it's optimal also it has the log
and regret so it's good in the average
in the IRD case when your data is not
worst case and it's good in the worst
case so yeah there's these two features
and it's a trivial noise and the noise
is interesting in itself it's just throw
data away right and this could have many
implications because look this this
problem with the dot loss and this
simple hedge setting which customs on
the way the maternity algorithm has it's
a pair digna thing that is used all over
you could do logistic regression and
then drop your gradients set your
gradients to zero uniformly with
probability 1/2 and maybe again there's
no tuning I don't know open so we have
theoreticians we work bottom up and
prove things about very simple things
and we prove that drop out in this
particular case works then we had a lot
of fun ok so there is many fancy
algorithms that achieve this but they're
very complex they have potentials they
have you know they're versions of the
Hedgehog on with fancier things in the
exponent and so forth very beautiful
work
rob's appears a group timber nerve and
and also you are Freund
at San Diego did work on Brown boost
very beautiful algorithms but
significantly more complicated than drop
out and
this dropout is interesting in its own
right I think ok now how did we run into
this yes just judge you what to do oh
that would be it would be a lily I would
be nervous about that because you could
have lots of zeroes we show in our proof
that the hard case for this set up is
when this row has only single ones so
when will you do your flipping it would
introduce a lot of stuff maybe with some
maybe with flipping not with probability
fifty-fifty with the tune probability
who knows I mean anything is possible
yeah we don't know yes yes we know
constants yes there's pretty parts of
the proof that I talked about and then
there's very complicated ugly
computations right so yeah there is
constants not high not high though not
all in the order of 4 or 5 right not not
hundreds I'm not hiding something ok and
you can run these algorithms and they
work well I'm not hiding anything so
it's not the theory theoretical computer
science talk where I'm hiding something
it's there's no oh it's not fair to put
an edge it's small constants the else
star in there can't you get like a
tighter grip and replace with like some
of like losses of that's expert it like
squared isn't when you can get better
bounce tastes better balance where you
have quadratic terms in here yes the but
they require a fancier algorithm yeah
and I want to talk about something
simple here
use me that like that one gives you the
optimal dependence on like T and F and
star on L star not not fancier versions
of expressions here yeah yes so I'm
doing something I'm not sure whether I
wouldn't our algorithm actually it's
essentially he's hinting at algorithms
that don't just take the total loss into
account but also some variance that
thing okay and this is the the question
whether drop out has good has has also
good properties when the variance is
small of the of the best expert
that's beautiful research topic yes the
kind of thing the kind of thing that I
have tried with variance is various
algorithms to do the following you look
at the the leader set and you only do
perturbations there you only drop those
and we have a bunch of algorithms and we
have huge simulations the damn thing we
can't prove anything about them so we
are in unfortunately I'm in a theory
community and I cannot publish it if I
would be in an experimental community I
would just publish things on a big
amount of data and they would have a
beautiful paper but I can't good good
good practical work is very very tricky
and good experimental papers are very
tricky so I'm and just being funny in
the limit you're getting a normal
distribution on your town yes how about
multiplying yes yes that would be
similar yes this would be smooth yes yes
would work or variations of that would
work and ended but sometimes you you can
you have to watch out if you I did
binary losses and if you have epsilon
losses you can do it
trick you sort of give everybody a small
amount of epsilon loss and then you
figure out where the leader is and then
you hit it and in the worst case you
need to binarize your problem there was
a little detail they subtleties anyway
but let me give you a little bit of a
flavor how this works okay so I has good
in the worst case and that's fancy
algorithms okay good good and they have
other advantages variance font so how
did we get into this we didn't want to
analyze that hedge hedge setting at all
we wanted to we were after matrix
problem well it turns out there's a
beautiful matrix generalization of these
kind of softmax algorithms the loss
vectors become lost matrices here the
losses between 0 & 1 these are positive
matrices with eigen values between 0 & 1
this will go by a little bit but you get
the flavor okay so probability
distributions on experts become density
matrices density matrices are the
eigenvalues are the probabilities and
then you have an eigen system as well
it's quantum physics kind of probability
distributions then this is the hedge
algorithm soft min it's also used in
boosting in many many contexts whenever
you have entropy regularization and then
there's a matrix hedge version where you
take the total of all these lost
matrices and you matrix exponentiate
them normalize and that gives you a
density matrix and this was used to
learn principal component analysis
because there you take care of a
subspace and this this kind of takes
care not just this takes you of the best
experts and this is the best subspace in
some sense all of these algorithms take
order n cube per update one of the
biggest problems in this online
community is get this down to N squared
well if you could do some kind of a drop
out where the dropping is very simple
where you drop the whole matrices right
you would add them up and just look for
the best eigenvalue good get it down to
N squared so we were we are obsessed
with getting it down to N squared we
haven't been able to make our proofs go
through and this gets to follow the
skipping leader follow the skin
leader would be we have a beautiful name
but no paper follow the skipping leader
is like you drop the whole row but
probability 1/2 right that's the natural
thing to do not these independence thing
or in the matrix case it would be you
drop each loss matrix that you come with
probability 1/2 you sit to 0 and then
you add them up and you do maximum eigen
value minimum eigen value computation
something like that yes that would get
it down to N squared but it's kind of
like an online bagging type thing but
then Gergely noi showed me they showed
us a counter example that this it
doesn't work if you want I show you at
the end very beautiful okay so our proof
techniques break down we were very upset
about it so we settled for writing about
the hedge algorithm again so this was
the Gaussian noise that gave us this
counter example ok so how does this all
relate where this hedge algorithm from
combo h are gonna miss you regularized
with a gradient descent that makes it
somewhat proper then that's how you have
avoid the slippy nosov the linear loss
it turns out this is kind of an
interesting fact that if you edit it you
do additive noise with long exponential
sometimes called the Gumbel distribution
then you get the H algorithm
so this follow-the-leader with additive
noise can simulate the hedgehog rhythm
okay that was kind of a funny exercise
that we had to do it was a couple of
nips back there was many papers on this
but drop out I don't know what the
regularization is there's many many
papers that try to figure out what kind
of regularization is drop out and it's a
mess it's very common oh it's another
may it's very complicated and the answer
is not clear but in this particular
single horn case we did it does
something good okay so proof methods
okay good now let's say and I had
discussions with algorithm about this
kind of things before
I'll show you so follow the leader
follow the leaders you just predict with
one guy with the best let's all maybe
predicted a monistic aliy then the
adversary knows what you do and he gives
you a unit loss after T trials you get
two units of loss but there's one guy
which has t over any of an expert en
loss so your regret is huge your regret
is going to be you know roughly a factor
of n times l star and it should be
square root of L star log n so that's
very bad because the the adversary can
fool you
right the adversary can hit you just
what you predict so if you hedge your
bets by predicting uniformly amongst the
best you're ready much better and this
was an algorithm that you showed me
years ago so so this was the optimum so
now you do FL with random dice so what
you do is you run you assume there's an
expert with no loss and you get your
lost vectors and you wipe out the ones
that have lost until you run out of
experts and then you start with a new
set and if you do that / sweep / / face
you can make at most log n loss and you
can see that by doing the following if
the adversary gives you one unit if only
one expert has a unit loss and you
predict uniformly you get one over n
loss one over n expected loss and then
afterwards you have n minus one expected
let experts left and it's this harmonic
sum so per face you can show you could
milk it make it most log in loss so in
total it's L star log and regret so this
is a huge jump from linear to this by
using randomness it's still not the
square root yeah to get to this you need
to do other tricks and you do drop out
for instance so what we prove is we
prove that our dropout algorithm has the
following very simple property the proof
technique is in two interesting in its
own right okay so if your loss factor
looks like this
chiliad then you could
say it's an adversary's advantage to
take that loss vector apart take put it
into three trials and give you one unit
of loss each time you understand it
makes you can prove that it makes you
incur more loss follow-the-leader also
has that property follow the leader with
Brenda with breaking ties uniformly also
has the unit rule as its worst case so
we call that the unit rule it I
discovered this first with papers with
Jake Abernathy and yes so that's a
beautiful thing that simplifies things
so you only have to concern yourself
with the adversary plane units and now
we're going to say we're going to
consider we're going to prove that we
can assume the worst case happens when
the adversary place them in a particular
order the unit's we'll see that in a
moment okay so this is the unit rule
okay so now what happens is the
following is if you have a particular
assume you're done with your whole
experiment and expert one got nine units
of loss eight units of loss this is the
loss profile that you have at the end
now the it was played by playing units
so each of them has a number associated
with maybe this one is played first
second third fourth fifth sixth seventh
you know they were you walked through
those units from left to right in a
particular order then we figured out
which order is worst which which is best
for the adversary which is worse for the
algorithm and it turns out you
essentially have to take them layer by
layer by because we showed that if you
take this one before this one then by
swapping you cure more loss you get the
idea so the worst case pattern is always
this sweeps now it sweeps and then
here's your loss of the best and then
you sweep some more that's the worst
case pattern so that's the only thing
yes let's simplifies the proof there's
still an ugly part left but let me let
me now tell you how much you pay per
sweep do you remember that follow the
leader
paid log n per sweep so we have to get
rid of that log n right
and we do know that the only worst case
for that out
it's worst case for this algorithm yes
so if I if I have a sweep like this I
would stay uniformed
I understand if it's a pattern if the
worst case pattern is this then I would
stay uniformed
I predict uniform with an expert I would
keep one unit of loss each time and then
at this point what I would finish I
would know this that there is one guy
that doesn't have any more loss so I
would take L star plus one loss but
that's cheating against that algorithm I
can fool it in a different way yes but
you get into the spirit good good so so
I assume you have s leaders at this
point right but you have the history
already dropped out thinks you have s
leaders and now you do a sweep all the
ones that are non leaders you can ignore
now I'm asking you how much loss do you
get per sweep and here's the deep
insight and it's very pretty and if we
just were fascinated by this okay so be
I showed you already that if you take
follow the leader which is the algorithm
that uses intuitively obvious you if you
picked a random one then on the first
trial you make one away s loss then the
number of experts goes down you picked
another random one and one s minus 1 you
sum this up log s bad because you have
if you end leaders in the worst case you
say log n per sweep huge too big too big
what a strap I do I claim dropout spends
constant loss on this pattern constant
and it's totally bizarre so what it does
and I first I show you the wrong proof
okay so I shouldn't tell you okay so you
do 1 over s now what happens is you drop
the leader with probability 1/2 so
afterwards you have only 1 over s minus
1/2 leaders roughly then you have 1 over
s minus 2 half leaders
right and afterwards you have one over s
minus 1 over 1/2 so basically you have
this thing now if you add this up it's a
constant because it's the tail of the
Harmonia morning
you know this harmonic sum is huge
right around here most this is where
most of its log and loss is over here as
a constant yeah so so you can rescale it
and so forth and you get to log in now I
cheated a little bit I used to Jensen's
inequality the wrong way but you can
compute this kind of calculation this
dropout on the sweet precisely with the
recurrence my co-author Vortech Kowalski
genius and then you show that it's
constant loss per sweep piece all right
so again what's happening follow the
leader
it's something very basic follow the
leader has lost does everybody
understand that 1 over s 1 over s minus
1 down to 1 and this is the harmonic
series citrus log n log s now if I do
drop out then my number of leaders drops
down slower because you see I'm going to
if you pick a random expert once in a
while if I will put stuff on something
that had been had its unit already in
the sweep and that helps me or something
like that
so I go down only slower I go down
slower with this sum and that sum is you
know this term goes like this it looks
like this it goes up and over here's all
the log and cost the total of the but
initially these things are so small that
they sum up to 2 log 2 you still
constant factor larger than
I'm going to okay so the picture is here
I never can make more than a constant
loss now if I have L star of this it
would be a constant time L star too big
so but it turns out we should now show
and this is the ugly part and we learned
that from girl annoy and negotiate that
with high probability after a while you
have only one guy one leader and in that
case we do we treat that as a special
case and we went so when we use their
theorem to show that most of the time
it's actually one and if it's one we're
perfect and when it's not bigger than
one we just plug in a constant C so it's
you you got you got the gist of course
because he teaches this stuff so so let
that the simplest case is again let's
say we have zero no no noise what's
going on what's going on if you have no
nice you follow the leader with uniform
ties broken again you have that log n
cost which is optimal you can prove its
optimal the algorithm the dropout pays
constant we know that the sweeping is
the best one
it pays constant per sweep but each time
each time reduces the number of expert a
half and it tastes log and sweep and you
can show it's it's to log in slightly
worse but totally different it arrives
that the unique expert totally
differently because it drops things it's
very beautiful
okay so I focus on the first l sweeps
most of the time the number of the
leaders is small and then this is more
complicated anyway
if you tune hedge based on the optimum
learning rate it looks like this it
takes constant for these kind of things
and then it flattens out ours goes up
like this and then flattens out at the
end this is the case where L star
happens anyway the bounds are optimal is
quite a
pretty okay so we're not interested in
proving things for single neurons yes we
also want to do more complicated things
but we don't know the unit rule breaks
down our proof techniques break down we
have it's insane you know we're just
lucky to find this little morsel but
then of course the correlates are
supposed to prove by the students or the
other people but it's much harder that
you go the e key thing is you always
have to be first and prove the first
beautiful result right and that we were
lucky here so the matrix case is still
open
maybe there's a trick we don't know if
you of course go in there and I can
decompose each loss vector and do all
kinds of things then maybe you can do it
but I don't know so we want to get this
to order N squared and they're really
annoying thing is there is another
algorithms called ojos algorithm which
runs in order in for pca for instance
and we don't know how whether that works
in the worst case so that's there's
layers of Oakland problems for us very
very challenging problems I've worked
with people my research is always is a
sequence of obsessions this is one of my
obsessions cracking in this matrix
problems I have not succeeded ok now
this is a new kind of noise right and it
has these properties of some you know
you try to use it for other things try
to use it for convex losses drop
gradients by 50% do logistic regression
drop gradients with probability half
does itself tune interesting problem
right
don't know and then of course the tripod
for neural nets prove something about
them you know instead of just URIs --tx
so and also then this additive noise
where is used a lot for making things
private you know this new privacy thing
question can use drop out noise yeah you
take your data and you just drop half of
it
the computers today you can use your
algorithm on that on top of half of the
data and maybe it becomes robust in some
way yeah very very curious direction so
that's all questions yes not not the
plane head shall Gotham the one with the
with a soft min which is sort of the the
jewel of this community because it uses
these exponential weights it's it's
related to exponential families you know
it's it's really two Bayes rule this
kind of a thing no because you have to
tune the learning rate because you have
got loss but there is fancier algorithms
that put some squares up here and do all
kinds of other little tricks and you
have batteries of algorithms with
different learning rains and put some
other algorithm that more complicated I
am you know I'm very interesting work
beautiful work but still more
complicated my answer to this is the
following
okay this is a long story okay so this
is what I'm working on now here there's
an exponential the trick has to be that
you put here your replace the
exponential by a power distribution you
introduce the temperature into the
exponential not just the learning rate
up here but in temperature into the
exponential work with that and then you
need another temperature in your loss
function it gets more complicated you
need two temperatures that's what I'm
working on now and I think that two
temperature model when the two
temperatures diverge is going to get
this automatic tuning for a huge class
of problems but it involves
generalizations of the exponential
family and all kinds of other techniques
it's quite interesting yes yes let's say
instead of mourning wanting to learn
wanting to learn a single X but you want
to learn a set of experts it's up to you
I don't know you could yes so you could
do it for sets of experts you could
still do you know unit maybe the unit
world holds I think we checked that I
don't remember what we have there okay
so in each case it's a special case
right you could make up all kinds of
problems the trick that we worked on
here is we brought it down to units and
then analyzed that special case yeah
please work on it it's very beautiful
yes has always been that you're
essentially having an implicit ensemble
with
wait is that is that that view give an
interpretation in this setting I don't
know if you if we go out on a buck to a
bar and you give me a bunch of beers I
will also talk that way but I'm in an
official position here in front
no don't know
yes Phillip I'd follow your intuition
everybody starts with intuitions right
and then you follow them and then you
but you have to prove things
unfortunately unless you have a lot of
data and you can make your point with
data then then you can also do it yes
somebody said something yes I think log
N squared maybe there is some stuff used
with gout done with Gaussian noises
noise I don't remember all the details
there there could be possible yes but
there's been a snobbish community and
called they want to get the optimum
bound they would scoff at that and they
wouldn't even write a paper on it I'm
serious
you gotta get the optimum